whenever I stay at a White Lotus I
always have a memorable time always
welcome to the White Lotus in Sicily
[Music]
you guys are here to learn about your
Sicilian Roots sounds like a fun boys
trip it wasn't supposed to be a boys
trip or a family vacation right now and
it's just the three of us because all
the women in our family hate you
please can we just drop it
now that he's loaded you think he
regrets marrying such a dud what is
going on with you there's a reason they
invited us here it's like you sold your
company you got rich and now he's your
best friend are these the kind of people
we're gonna be hanging out with now did
you vote babe be honest I did
the night it doesn't matter
flirting is one of the pleasures of life
you're 80 years old but the women I
desire remain young you can relate to
that
I just wanted to inform you that my good
friends here they're going to be
visiting me this week coming and going
thank town
and go see you later bye
why isn't your assistant to a vacation
with your husband it's not like she's
gonna be in our bed and stuff
I don't know what's going on with Greg
but I think it's [ __ ] I think he's
having an affair I've seen a lot of guys
who are like make all this money and
they just start acting different you
guys party
that's fun that's fun
[Music]
A man does what he has to do but you
keep it tight
if you're sloppy it's like you're
rubbing their faces
what happened last night just been a
series of very bad decisions
we've had very bad luck
best thing about Market is
I can always change
Italy's just so romantic you're gonna
die we're gonna have to drag you out of
here